As 2021 dawned, nearly every industry on
Earth was still suffering the effects of 2020,
including the world of television. Here are
some of the familiar favorites leaving the
airwaves in 2021, and the
often strange reasons why.
“Peaky Blinders” is one
of the most ambitious crime dramas to ever grace
television. Based somewhat on the true story of
a street gang that terrorized Birmingham and other
parts of the U.K. in the years between World War I
and World War II, the dark, violent, and stylish
show evoked underworld sagas like “The Godfather”.
It also presented a view of the interwar
period rarely approached in media, along
with showcasing an all-star cast that included
Cillian Murphy, Tom Hardy, and Anya Taylor-Joy.
“Peaky Blinders” remained a popular,
much-discussed series well into its run,
both on the BBC in the U.K., and
on Netflix in the U.S. In May 2018,
creator Steven Knight told the “Birmingham
Press Club” just before the debut of season five
that a sixth season of “Peaky Blinders” was
on the way, with a seventh season likely,
if not probable. However, after pandemic-related
shutdowns delayed the shooting of season six,
Knight changed his plans. He told “Variety,”
"COVID came along, and we lost a year of
production. So we put our heads together
and thought that it would be a good idea to
do a movie instead of doing series seven."
That means “Peaky Blinders” fans
can at least look forward to that.
In 2016, HBO debuted “Insecure,”
starring co-creator Issa Rae as Issa Dee, a woman
in her late twenties trying to balance all the
different threads in her life while searching for
fulfillment and purpose. When the series begins,
Issa works at a Los Angeles nonprofit designed
to help young students of color succeed.
Acclaimed for being a thoughtful and vital look
at 21st century life for African-American women,
“Insecure” scored an Emmy nomination
for Outstanding Comedy Series.
Insecure was a fully fleshed-out, grander
realization of “Awkward Black Girl,”
Rae's confessional YouTube series from the
2010s. Along with co-creator Larry Wilmore,
Rae mapped out a show designed to tell a
finite story about a certain period in the
life of her character and her social
circle. Rae shared with “Deadline,”
"We always planned to tell this
story through five seasons."
HBO renewed the series for
its fifth season in May 2020,
which Rae confirmed in January
2021 would be its last.
Set in a police precinct deep in New York City,
“Brooklyn Nine-Nine” is one of the most acclaimed
sitcoms of the 2010s and beyond. Revolving around
the goofy but actually talented detective Jake
Peralta, who is played by Andy Samberg, the
crew of the “Nine-Nine” is more like a family.
It’s led by stone-faced captain Raymond Holt,
played by Andre Braugher, and involves neurotic
sergeant Terry Jeffords, played by Terry Crews,
Jake-worshipping detective Boyle, played by Joe Lo
Truglio, and self-absorbed community liaison Gina,
played by Chelsea Peretti. “Brooklyn Nine-Nine’s”
pull was strong, seeing that when Fox canceled
it in 2018, it was immediately revived by NBC.
“This isn’t over yet.”
“Brooklyn Nine-Nine's” eighth season was
delayed. Set to air during the 2019-2020 season,
coronavirus-related shutdowns of Hollywood
productions pushed back those episodes. Then,
after a spate of deaths of African-Americans
at the hands of law enforcement, including
those of Breonna Taylor and George Floyd, the
anti-police-brutality and overall anti-police
sentiment that in part fueled coast-to-coast
protests led to a reckoning over cop shows.
Shows thought to glorify police, like “Cops” and
“Live P.D.,” were immediately canceled. Producers
for “Brooklyn Nine-Nine,” a gentle comedy about
police officers, tossed all the scripts written
for its eighth season in order to start over
with recent events in mind. All of this weighed
heavily on an aging show that was not a ratings
hit. NBC announced that “Brooklyn Nine-Nine”
would return for its eighth and final season in
2021, with a limited run of just 10 episodes.
OWN's “The Haves and the Have Nots” is a
good old-fashioned 1980s-style, scandal-free,
family drama-loaded primetime soap. Set in the
beautiful and moneyed city of Savannah, Georgia,
the story centers in part on the locally dominant
Cryers and Harringtons, who have abundant wealth
and resources at their disposal. Those are the
"haves," while the "have nots" are the Youngs,
a working-class family led by single mother Hanna,
played by Crystal Fox, who works in the home of
the Cryers. There's plenty of intrigue with the
servants, as well as when the two sides of the
socioeconomic coin interact, making for a show
that feels like a modern-day “Downton Abbey.”
The series comes from the mind of prolific
show creator and producer Tyler Perry.
In 2017, he signed a deal to make scripted
series for the channel. The first show under
that deal was “The Haves and the Have Nots,” OWN's
first scripted series, which drew an average of
three million viewers, which was huge for the
sometimes struggling network. After a run of
eight years and nearly 200 episodes, “The Haves
and the Have Nots” will end its run in May 2021,
the last vestige of Perry's contract with the
Oprah Winfrey Network. He moved on from the
channel in 2017, signing a development deal to
make shows for Viacom outlets, including “BET.”
The end of this show marks a clean, contractual
break with Perry's former creative home.
“Mom” was a tricky sitcom from day one,
but the cast and crew pulled it off.
Co-created by “Two and a Half Men” and “The
Big Bang Theory” mastermind Chuck Lorre,
“Mom” mined humor from addiction recovery.
“Scary Movie” star Anna Faris played Christy,
a recovering alcoholic in the early stages of
putting her life back together while balancing
family responsibilities. She did all this while
dealing with the handful that was her mother,
Bonnie, played by Allison Janney, also
dealing with her own addiction issues.
In September 2020, just days before “Mom” was
set to start production on its eighth season,
Faris abruptly walked away from the series. When
the show returned to the air two months later,
“Mom” writers got rid of Christy by explaining
that she'd moved away to attend law school at
Georgetown University. Months later, CBS announced
that “Mom” would end at the conclusion of its
only season without Faris. The show arguably
couldn't suffer the blow of losing its star,
but Christy's exit also marked the
final step in the “Mom” story arc.
When the show began in 2013, it was a vehicle for
Faris, and the action centered on her character,
a single mother raising two children. Over
time, the kids were completely written out and
the spotlight moved over to Christy's mother
Bonnie, and her Alcoholics Anonymous group.
The “NCIS” format follows highly-trained
Naval Criminal Investigative Service agents as
they investigate and solve Navy-related crimes.
The “NCIS” premise is one that keeps on giving.
Since 2003, the franchise has generated more
than 400 episodes of the Washington, D.C. based
“NCIS,” nearly 300 of spinoff “NCIS: Los Angeles,”
and about 150 of “NCIS: New Orleans,”
starring veteran TV actor Scott Bakula
as team leader Supervisory Special Agent Dwayne
Cassius Pride. This iteration of the crime
procedural saga hit CBS in 2014, and at one point,
ranked among the top 10 most watched shows on TV.
But that was years ago. In February 2021, CBS
announced that “NCIS: New Orleans” would end at
the conclusion of its seventh season. The
cancellation comes in part due to falling
viewership. In the 2020-21 season, no CBS drama
suffered a bigger drop than “NCIS: New Orleans,”
which also loses 750,000 viewers from its lead-in
show, “NCIS: Los Angeles,” and accumulates a total
draw of about half of the original “NCIS.”
It especially didn't make sense for CBS to
keep making new episodes of the New Orleans
series because it didn't generate big money in
reruns and on streaming, the way the other two
NCIS shows do. Meanwhile, “NCIS: New Orleans”
showrunners have already agreed to take over
a potential new CBS drama: “NCIS: Hawaii.”
With four distinct iterations airing decades
apart, “The Twilight Zone” is one of the most
oft-revived shows in TV history. The original,
hosted by creator Rod Serling, aired from 1959
to 1964, followed by a 1985 to 1989 version,
another from 2002 to 2003, and a fourth, debuting
in 2019 on CBS All Access. Standing in for Serling
was Academy Award-winning “Get Out” and “Us”
filmmaker Jordan Peele, who also co-developed
the show. Like its predecessor, this modern-day
“Twilight Zone” told spooky, unsettling,
and hard-to-forget stories of fright, dread,
regret, and other dark parts of the human psyche.
Right around the time that ViacomCBS prepared
to convert its CBS All Access service into
Paramount Plus, the producers in charge of this
latest "Twilight Zone" series announced that
they would not be making new episodes for the
rebooted streamer. Peele and co-producer Simon
Kinberg decided that they'd accomplished what
they'd set out to do. According to the “New York
Daily News” Peele and Kinberg's production
companies shared a joint statement, saying,
"After 20 unique episodes, we have told
the stories that we wanted to tell,
and CBS All Access was gracious in
their understanding of our decision."
“Wynnona Earp” is one of the wildest
and most original TV series in recent memory.
The show depicts the adventures of the modern-day
descendant of strong-armed Old West lawman Wyatt
Earp, who returns to her Rocky Mountains hometown
where she does battle with "revenants,” the
supernatural monster versions of the 19th century
scofflaws her great-great-grandfather
killed in the line of duty.
The show debuted in the U.S. on Spike in 2016,
and after three seasons moved to SyFy for season
four. That network was supposed to air a fifth
season before reversing course in February 2021,
announcing that the fourth run would be the last
for "Wynnona Earp". It's a near miracle that those
episodes were even finished. Production company
IDW ran out of money, which delayed filming for
almost a year. SyFy agreed to foot the bill, but
then the pandemic led to a shutdown shortly after
filming began. And then, SyFy's parent company,
NBCUniversal, restructured its programming
strategy, deciding to emphasize streaming
content instead of cable network originals.
“Killing Eve” is a thrilling show — a darkly
comic, action-packed, high-stakes chase drama
about a brutal, globetrotting assassin named
Villanelle, played by Jodie Comer and Sandra
Oh’s character Eve, the American-born British
intelligence officer in constant pursuit.
They're both obsessed with one another
for varied and complicated reasons,
and in its early seasons, “Killing Eve"
was one of the hottest shows on TV,
in the U.K. and in the U.S., with Oh winning
a Golden Globe and Comer winning an Emmy.
The show has a very finite premise —
eventually, Eve and Villanelle have
to come face to face for a final showdown,
with one winner and one loser — and in 2021,
AMC announced that the show would end after its
fourth season. Those episodes were delayed due
to pandemic-related production shutdowns, and
the season will consist of only eight episodes,
which are set to air in 2022. However,
while “Killing Eve” is dead, the franchise
will continue. In a statement, AMC original
programming president Dan McDermott shared,
“[The network is] exploring potential
extensions of this compelling universe."
So, hopefully, some kind of spinoff is on the way.
Celebrated and immensely popular fantasy author
Neil Gaiman published one of his masterworks in
2001, the novel “American Gods.” The story depicts
the ancient mythological and religious deities
of Europe, Africa, and Asia brought to the United
States over centuries of immigration and diaspora,
struggling to stay alive as their
adherents die out and also waging a
battle with powerful "new gods" like Media
and the technology allegory Technical Boy.
It's a complicated, heady brew, and
it was often held up as an example
of an "unfilmable" work, a novel
impossible to reasonably adapt to film.
And yet, in 2017, Starz brought “American Gods”
to the small screen, in the form of a continuing
weekly series in the hands of screenwriter Michael
Green and Bryan Fuller. However, “American Gods”
experienced a lot of backstage issues. Toward
the end of the show's first season, showrunners
Green and Fuller departed, unable to resolve
creative differences with Starz executives,
and cast members Kristin Chenoweth and
Gillian Anderson followed them out the door.
More showrunners came and went, actors reportedly
rewrote their own scripts to improve them,
and then cast member Orlando Jones was fired,
which he believes was racially motivated.
Starz ended the whole thing in March
2021, announcing that “American Gods'”
already-aired third season — which ended
with a cliffhanger — would be the show's
last. The network added that a finale movie
or miniseries in the future was a possibility.
Creator Emily Spivey, a writer for “Parks
and Recreation” and “King of the Hill,”
based “Bless the Harts” on elements and
characters from her North Carolina hometown.
The animated family sitcom is
loaded with comedic heavy hitters,
with Kristen Wiig voicing single mother
and fish restaurant waitress Jenny Hart,
Maya Rudolph portraying Jenny's aggressive
and wild mother, Betty, Ike Barinholtz as
Jenny's boyfriend, Wayne, and Jillian Bell
as Jenny's artsy teenage daughter, Violet.
A show full of crackling comedy and heart, “Bless
the Harts” fit right in on Fox's Sunday night
animation lineup alongside similar series like
“The Simpsons” and “Bob's Burgers.” However,
in the midst of the show's second season, Fox
announced that it would not order a third season.
The reason? Not just bad ratings but extremely
bad ratings. In season two, “Bless the Harts”
pulled in only 1.3 million viewers on average,
making it Fox's lowest-rated Sunday night show
and second least-watched show
of the 2020-21 season overall.
In the midst of the great mid-2010s
reboot and revival craze that returned
everything from “Twin Peaks” to
“Murphy Brown” to television,
CBS ordered a new version of “MacGyver.”
The original show premiered in 1985,
and this innovative action series focused on a
brilliant secret agent, played by Richard Dean
Anderson, whose aversion to firearms meant that
he had to use his wits and whatever items he could
find to save the day and beat the bad guys.
On the new “MacGyver,” which debuted in 2016,
Lucas Till played the role, only his version
was younger and more charming of a rogue.
“MacGyver” was a top 30 hit in its first year,
but by its fifth — and ultimately final – season,
it ranked #10 in viewership of CBS'
14 dramas. Prior to the season,
CBS fired executive producer Peter M. Lenkov for
fostering a difficult work environment, bolstered
by allegations from Till in “Vanity Fair” that
he'd been verbally abused and body-shamed on
set to the degree that he'd felt suicidal. And
CBS was also involved in a “MacGyver” lawsuit.
In December 2018, the rights holders of the
original “MacGyver” sued over unpaid royalties
generated by the new series. According to
“Deadline,” just before canceling the show,
CBS released a statement calling out the suit
for, quote, "fatal, incurable deficiencies."
If you or someone you know is having suicidal
thoughts, please call the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline at 1-800-273-TALK (8255)
or text HOME to the Crisis Text Line at 741741.
Plenty of comedians have hit in big in
their native United Kingdom and then
similarly found fame and fortune in
North America, like Sacha Baron Cohen,
Ricky Gervais, and the members of Monty
Python. Katherine Ryan did the opposite.
Born and raised in Canada, she became a popular
comic and panel show guest in England. In 2020,
Netflix in the U.S. attempted to bring Ryan closer
to home, picking up "The Duchess," a six-episode
sitcom starring and created by the comedian. Ryan
portrayed a character also named Katherine, a
single mother looking to expand her family if she
can find a man worthy enough of being the father.
Overall, critics hailed "The Duchess," but Netflix
didn't think enough subscribers gave it a shot.
On an episode of "The Secret To..."
podcast released in April 2021,
Ryan revealed that no more episodes of
"The Duchess" would be produced, saying,
"I think something like 10 million people
watched it in 28 days, and that wasn't enough.”
There's also the issue of Ryan's schedule. A few
weeks before "The Duchess" news broke, Netflix
competitor Amazon signed her to make a new comedy
show called "Backstage with Katherine Ryan."
It's a testament to the quality and universality
of Sherlock Holmes that more than 130 years after
the character created by Sir Arthur
Conan Doyle made his literary debut,
filmmakers and screenwriters are still
coming up with new and innovative ways
to present and interpret the world of
the brilliant, deductive detective.
And in March 2021, the eight-episode first
season of "The Irregulars" hit Netflix,
detailing the adventures
of the scrappy, streetwise,
19th-century London ragamuffins who act as helpers
and informants for Holmes. Out of the gate,
"The Irregulars" was a major hit, ranking at
one point as the most-watched show on streaming,
with viewers watching 643 million minutes' worth
and spending 18 straight days in Netflix's top 10.
Why Netflix decided against identifying "The
Irregulars" as a show it could renew is a
mystery only Sherlock Holmes himself could solve.
Not only was "The Irregulars" a bona fide smash,
but the streaming service gave no
reason for its April 2021 decision.
"The Last Kingdom" first hit TV screens in 2015
as a BBC series, and then Netflix brought the
sweeping historical drama — which occupied
a similar niche as shows like "Outlander"
and "Vikings" — to stateside audiences in 2018.
Based on "The Saxon Stories," the bestselling
13-novel series by Bernard Cornwell, "The Last
Kingdom" is set in the British Isles in the late
800s, where Saxons have to contend with Vikings,
invading hordes, and power struggles. Alexander
Dreymon stars as Uhtred, a warrior deeply
conflicted about where his loyalties ought to lie.
In April 2021, production company Carnival
Films, in conjunction with Netflix,
announced that the fifth season of "The Last
Kingdom" — at the time, in the middle of
production — would be the series' last. According
to a statement released by executive producer
Nigel Marchant, it sounds as if "The Last
Kingdom" has naturally reached the end,
or the near-end, of the story it set out to tell.
However, while the fifth season will reportedly be
based on the ninth and tenth books in Cornwell's
series, there are still two additional books that
will remain untouched, which is a little
curious. Regardless, as Marchant put it,
"We're excited to give viewers a chance to follow
Uhtred on the next stage of his epic
quest, where not everyone survives."
"Prodigal Son" was a dark crime procedural,
but it offered a twist on the enduring format.
A riff on "The Silence of the Lambs," the
series centered on New York Police Department
criminal profiler Malcolm Bright, played by
Tom Payne, who got into the minds of suspects
by consulting a notorious, captured serial
killer played by Michael Sheen. "Prodigal
Son" was one part cat-and-mouse game, one part
unconventional father-son-reconnecting drama.
In May 2021, “TVLine” reported that Fox had
decided against ordering a third season of
"Prodigal Son," meaning that it's already shot
and edited second-season finale would serve as
a series capper. According to a Fox insider,
executives really liked the show and wanted
to make it work, but its ratings were so low
that it wouldn't make economic sense to do so.
"Prodigal Son" viewership numbers fell
nearly 40 percent in its second season,
and it was the least-watched drama
still standing on the Fox schedule.
With the breadth and ambition of a gigantic novel,
"This Is Us" has told both the big and
small stories in the lives of the Pearsons,
often jumping forward or backward in time to
depict every major moment in the family's history,
as well as the causes and aftermath. An
emotionally driven and tear-jerking show,
"This Is Us" has been a massive hit for NBC
and earned Emmy nominations and wins for most
of its primary cast, including Sterling K.
Brown, Milo Ventimiglia, and Mandy Moore.
In May 2019, NBC gave "This Is Us" a three-season
renewal, ensuring the timeline-hopping family
drama would stay on the air through its sixth year
and the 2021-22 season. That would turn out to be
the last time NBC would order more episodes of
"This Is Us." When the network announced its
plans for 2021-22 in May 2021, it confirmed that
"This Is Us" would air its last episodes during
that time. This isn't really a true cancelation,
however — six seasons was part of the master plan.
After year three, showrunner Isaac Aptaker
told “Deadline” that the series would end
in about three seasons in the future, and in 2020,
creator Dan Fogelman told the "Los Angeles Times",
"By the time we're in our sixth season,
you'll have a lot of the information
about what's happened to this family, and
what will be left is some resolution."
“We’re all gonna be fine.”
In 2003, amidst the traditionally combative,
confrontational, and personal problems-oriented
world of daytime talk programs, viewers were
treated to the "The Ellen DeGeneres Show."
The host, the dry and deadpan comedian
best known for the '90s sitcom "Ellen,"
injected late-night style fun into her afternoon
show, engaging in light-hearted interviews with
celebrities, when she wasn't pranking them, as
well as recognizing and rewarding local heroes
and then dancing through every spare moment.
In May 2021, DeGeneres told “The Hollywood
Reporter” that she would shut down "The Ellen
DeGeneres Show" when her contract to host the
series ended in 2022. The main reason? It
no longer thrilled her. DeGeneres shared,
"When you're a creative person, you
constantly need to be challenged,
and as great as this show is, and as fun as
it is, it's just not a challenge anymore."
DeGeneres may also be bailing on a sinking TV
ship. Ratings had fallen by nearly half from
2020 to 2021, in the wake of allegations
and revelations that "The Ellen DeGeneres
Show" was a workplace fraught
with hostility and misbehavior.
Over its first seven years, "Black-ish" fit in
nicely with ABC's line-up of domestic sitcoms like
"Modern Family" and "The Middle," but it was also
much more thoughtful and ambitious than the usual
exasperated-working-parents-with-rambunctious-kids
shows. Created by Kenya Barris, "Black-ish"
starred Anthony Anderson and Tracee Ellis Ross as
Dre and Bow Johnson, parents of four attempting to
raise their children into well-rounded and
self-assured people while keeping wealthy
privilege in check and ensuring that they never
lose touch with their Black culture and identity.
In May 2021, ABC renewed but also canceled
"Black-ish," announcing that the thoughtful family
sitcom would return sometime in the 2021-22 season
for a final stretch of episodes. "Black-ish" just
might've run its course. Initially a show about
raising kids, most of the young characters had
come of age. The eldest Johnson daughter, Zoey,
was already spun off into the Freeform series
"Grown-ish." Furthermore, "Black-ish" was one of
the least-watched shows on network TV in 2019-20
season, and the ratings doldrums continued
in 2020-21, helping ABC make its decision.
"Mixed-ish," an '80s-set spinoff about the
childhood of Tracee Ellis Ross' character, Bow,
also didn't survive. ABC canceled the show after
two seasons in May 2021, effective immediately.
"American Housewife" was something of a throwback
to sitcoms of the '80s and '90s, depicting the
day-to-day lives of the argumentative and lightly
dysfunctional Otto family. Geeky dad Greg,
played by Diedrich Bader, and mischievous mom
Katy, played by Katy Mixon, kept watch over their
three headstrong kids — dumb teen Taylor, played
by Meg Donnelly, money-obsessed Oliver, played by
Daniel DiMaggio, and idiosyncratic Anna-Kat,
played by Julia Butters — while trying to remain
the only scrupulous and tight-knit family in a
superficial and ultra-wealthy Connecticut town.
Heading into its fifth season, "American
Housewife" faced personnel issues that it
couldn't quite overcome. Julia Butters,
who played Anna-Kat, left the show
after a breakout performance in Quentin
Tarantino's "Once Upon a Time in Hollywood."
The role was recast and the character
rewritten with Giselle Eisenberg. Carly Hughes,
who portrayed Katie Otto's friend and confidante
Angela, also departed, telling “Deadline,”
“[I] was no longer able to work in the toxic
environment that was created
on 'American Housewife.'"
She alleged discriminatory practices by superiors,
and after an internal investigation by ABC,
the creator and producer and a line producer
were no longer employed by the series. Nearly
two months after the fifth season finale aired,
it retroactively became a series finale
when ABC canceled "American Housewife."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.